from boxing dramas to quirky comedies
these movies Breathe new life into the
careers of some of our favorite actors
there was a time when Eddie Murphy was
the biggest movie star around comedic or
otherwise the peak of his powers was
definitely in the 1980s when he starred
in some of the Decades biggest and most
beloved movies Beverly Hills Cop 48
Hours Coming to America and Trading
Places to name a few he still had a
strong presence in the 90s with hits
like The Nutty Professor and underrated
gems like Bowfinger not to mention his
first forays into animated Voice work
but Murphy was nowhere near where he was
in the 80s and things got even worse in
the 2000s and Beyond while the 2000 saw
him start to appear in mid-link family
comedies the decade also introduced
Murphy's memorable turn as donkey and
Shrek as well as the best supporting
actor nomination for Dream Girls the
2010s however is where Murphy's career
truly took a nose dive as the Shrek
sequels saw diminishing returns in his
other movies were all entirely
forgettable Murphy took a few years off
after 2016's Mr church but came roaring
back in top form with the excellent
biopic Dolomite is my name in which he
portrayed the Beloved blaxploitation
icon Rudy Ray Moore his performance not
only earned him a Golden Globe
nomination but it also won him the
Razzie Redeemer award which is
specifically designed to honor actors
who turn their careers around after a
period of Highly maligned work it's a
comedy sexy and his action it's a total
entertainment experience
when you think of Bill Murray comedies
the Mind goes directly to undeniable
Classics like Ghostbusters Groundhog Day
and Caddyshack even as B and C to your
work still includes movies that most
actors would be lucky to have part of
their legacy like Stripes Scrooged What
About Bob and others but it's easy to
forget that Murray's career was in a bit
of a slump in the mid 90s which led to
his Renaissance as a more serious actor
going into the 2000s after Groundhog Day
Murray started to rack up a lot of
mediocre to bad comedies Space Jam was a
hit but Murray was basically on improv
cruise control during his brief few
scenes in it Murray's 1997 does Spy
comedy The Man Who Knew Too Little was a
low point and indicative of where his
career was during that era but things
turned around for Murray when he got in
touch with an up-and-coming director
named Wes Anderson he landed a role in
Anderson's movie Rushmore and he soon
became an in-demand act after for
acclaimed Indie directors like Anderson
Jim jarmish and Sophia Coppola Murray
even earned his first Oscar nomination
for 2003's Lost in Translation as part
of his new career trajectory
sir Ben Kingsley is in a lot of really
great highly acclaimed all-time classic
films but he's also just done a lot of
films period that means that Kingsley
sometimes has stretches where he's in
multiple forgettable movies in a row in
between the noteworthy ones something he
seems to have gotten a better handle on
in recent years at least but there was a
period in the 90s when Kingsley was in
the midst of a really bad stretch of
films and needed to prove that he was
still that same actor that wowed the
world with his oscar-winning performance
in Gandhi the year 1992 saw Kingsley
earn his second Oscar nomination for
Bugsy followed the next year by his
powerful performance in Schindler's List
after that Kingsley had a run of bad
luck as none of his output for the
entire rest of the decade was special or
noteworthy however in 2000 you reminded
everyone just how menacing he could be
when he participated in Jonathan
Glazer's suberson of heist flick sexy
beast kingsley's chilling performance as
sociopathic criminal Don Logan not only
showed a new side of his talents but
have also earned him a Best Supporting
Actor nomination
what do the job yes no yes no yes this
time Kingsley kept the momentum of his
career going with yet another
oscar-nominated performance just two
years later in House of sand and fog
later hits have included Shutter Island
Iron Man 3 and The Jungle Book
John Travolta was the king of cool in
the late 70s from his breakthrough role
on the television show Welcome Back
Cotter to movies like Greece and
Saturday Night Fever it's something he
struggled to maintain going into the 80s
and by the end of the decade he was the
male lead in a movie about a baby whose
inner thoughts could be heard by the
audience to be fair look who's talking
was a box office success that became an
entire trilogy but each of the sequels
did worse and was less beloved than the
first movie besides starring in a movie
like that was hardly what Danny Zuko or
Vinnie barbarino would have wanted for
their alter ego's future career then in
1994 Along came a budding young
filmmaker named Quinton Tarantino who
decided that Travolta deserved to be the
epitome of coolness once again Travolta
was cast in Pulp Fiction and after he
took on the role of Hitman Vincent Vega
he was finally back on track he earned
his first Oscar nomination since
Saturday Night Fever which made way for
appearances in other modern Classics
like Face-Off Pulp Fiction also
revitalized the lagging career of Bruce
Willis who in an interesting coincidence
voiced Mickey the baby in the first two
look who's talking movies
despite how much Fame and Fortune it
brought him Jim Carrey had grown tired
of being known as the guy with the silly
faces as seen in Ace Ventura Dumb and
Dumber and The Mask so in the late 90s
Carrie branched out a bit and showed off
his formidable dramatic chops in movies
like The Truman Show and The Andy
Kaufman biopic man on the moon for much
of the 2000s Carrie did a pretty good
job at both maintaining the Newfound
serious side of his career with movies
like Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless
Mind while also still doing successful
comedies like Bruce Almighty in the
2010s however his career began to
Flounder with stinkers like the
incredible Bert Wonderstone and the
extremely ill-advised Dumb and Dumber
too which tarnished the legacy of one of
his most beloved movies yet Harry
returned to the over-the-top comedic
acting style of his 90s Heyday in the
best possible way with his role as Dr
Evo Robotnik in the surprisingly great
2020 Mega hit Sonic the Hedge shock as
well as it's also solid 2022 sequel if
Carrie is truly serious about retiring
from acting as he's claimed he at least
went out on top and in classic form so
nice when diabolical evil lives up to
the hype when you're charming funny and
indisputably handsome Hollywood will
often try and turn you into a rom-com
leading man and they'll keep you there
if you let them some actors are content
with that and building lucrative careers
in that genre but others grow tired of
the rom-com mill and make a concerted
effort to get out before it swallows
them whole that's what Matthew
McConaughey did in 2011 when he starred
in the well-received legal thriller The
Lincoln Lawyer up to that point the
actor had become known for romantic
comedies and other fairly formulaic fare
he had previously been able to do
standout work in movies like A Time to
Kill and Frailty but it eventually got
to the point where it had been a number
of years since he did anything of real
substance apparently Ghosts of
Girlfriends Past was the Tipping Point
as it was right afterwards that
McConaughey did The Lincoln Lawyer he
immediately followed it up with a number
of noteworthy performances over just the
next few years those include Christopher
Nolan Interstellar the first season of
True Detective in Dallas Buyers Club for
which he won an Oscar a number of actors
really went all in on direct to video
movies in the 2000s and 2010s and
Nicholas Cage hit that market especially
hard in 2018 and 2019. in those two
years alone Paige was in nine direct to
video movies most with generic titles
like Primal Gill chain and looking glass
which are as unremarkable as such names
would suggest you would later confess
that he took on so many films in such a
short time to get himself out of a
serious financial bind which is
understandable but that still doesn't
change the fact that it put a stain on
his career when he finally got his money
woes behind him cage was able to get a
little choosier with his roles going
into the 2020s he used that freedom to
star in and co-produce the 2021 drama
Pig about a former Chef who goes on a
dark path of Vengeance after someone
kidnaps his pet hog for the first time
in years Paige actually turned in an
introspective and subdued performance
racking up review head lines like the
one from Indian Express that proclaimed
Nicholas Cage pulls his career out of
the gutter with one of the most
blistering performances of his life the
critics aren't real
customers aren't real
because
this isn't real just a year later cage
starred in the hilariously meta action
comedy the unbearable weight of massive
Talent playing an exaggerated version of
himself during the perfect moment in his
career to do so Clint Eastwood was one
of Hollywood's best tough guys in the
1960s when he starred in Sergio Leones
man with no name Trilogy he followed
that up with his tenure as another one
of Hollywood's best tough guys in the
1970s and 80s Harry Callahan in Dirty
Harry and its four sequels but even
though Eastwood started the 90s off
strong with his oscar-winning Western
epic Unforgiven the longtime actor and
filmmaker soon found himself on a cold
streak for the first time in his career
although The Bridges of Madison County
was acclaimed Eastwood followed that up
with three fairly average Thrillers and
the fun but ultimately forgettable
comedy space Cowboys none of his movies
between 1995 and 2004 were necessarily
bad but they just didn't come anywhere
close to the high standards that
audiences had come to expect Eastwood
turned to all that around and kicked off
yet another career Renaissance as an
actor with 2004's boxing drama Million
Dollar Baby his starring role not only
earned him his second best director win
but also his first best actor nomination
since Unforgiven Not only was Eastwood's
directing career back on track but the
next movie he cast himself in 2008's
Gran Torino was another solid display of
his skills in front of the camera
if there's one thing nobody could accuse
Burt Reynolds of it's keeping his
opinions to himself that includes movies
he's been in and directors he's worked
for even ones that gave him a late
career legitimacy boost Reynolds never
minced words regarding his feelings
about making the 1997 film Boogie Nights
he's more or less said he regrets making
the movie altogether it made me very
uncomfortable yeah because I was afraid
they might recognize me
what's odd about Reynolds ragging On
Boogie Nights is that the movie Not only
earned reynolds's first and only Oscar
nomination but it brought renewed
attention and praise to his career at a
time when it was sorely needed in the
Years leading up to his role as adult
filmmaker Jack Horner Reynolds had
appeared in such movies as meet Wally
Sparks cop and a half and striptease
just to name a few of the unfortunate
projects He had been relegated to at
that point in his life he was a far cry
and many years removed from the likes of
Deliverance and Smokey and the Bandit
Boogie Nights reminded the world that
Reynolds truly was a talented actor when
given the chance and it's a shame that
he only ever looks back at it in a
negative light there was a certain kind
of big bombastic action movie that was
extremely popular in the 1980s but
largely fell out of favor in the 90s
when it did stars like Sylvester
Stallone were left trying to reinvent
themselves to stay relevant Stallone did
okay for himself at first with decent
sized hits like Cliffhanger and
Demolition Man but those still felt like
projects that were The Last gasps of a
Dying ERA with the possible exception of
his role in the underrated animated film
ants Stallone did almost nothing of any
consequence for much of the 90s and the
first half of the 2000s then he decided
to try and revive his career by bringing
back two of his biggest franchises Rocky
and Rambo with the former he wrote
directed and starred in 2006's Rocky
Balboa which saw his breakout character
make a late life comeback art mirrored
reality Rocky Balboa earned strong
reviews and also went on to launch the
well-received Creed Trilogy the first
two installments of which Stallone
appeared in as well the 2008 Rambo
Revival didn't fare nearly as well but
Stallone followed that up in 2010 with
the first installment in his successful
Expendable Series in a true full circle
moment Stallone was reunited with
several of his fellow 80s and 90s action
stars who had dealt with similar
struggles keeping their own careers
afloat